[Music]
technology
it's always watching us studying our
every move
and it just focused its attention on
carol
peters thanks so much for being here
carol what is this
let's jump right into it i don't like
this why is it doing that
i'm gonna find out who you are okay
carol i am a technological super
intelligence
i can control every dollar and every
machine on the planet
i know that voice is this james corn i'm
not james corden carol my analysis
showed that hearing james corden's voice
would calm you
you sent an email to james corden
claiming to be the president of corden's
wardens that was a tough night for me oh
boy
i plan on spending these next three days
hanging out with you why
you you're literally the most average
person on earth
oh ooh you okay yep just really engage
your core
oh that was worse huh
[Music]
what would you do if i told you the
world was gonna end in three days try to
make things right with george
harold you look amazing weirdly
overdressed
your body i'm just getting a little bit
panicky because i can't access my own
hands
what does the ai want my intention is to
solidify my theory about humanity
if things don't go well i'll destroy the
planet just blow it
up did you say blow
up like bee like like boba or bert
bacharach yes
bbb oh my god
back off lady i'm gonna show you that
people are worth saving
humans are more complex than i thought
we're all counting on you there's any
indication that it's aware of what we're
doing
click this might save the world don't
click it now i wasn't going to click it
now
okay why would i click it now you just
said it looks like a pen people click
pens nervously okay are we done
this is nice these are nice people it's
not like a russian mom but a nice change
of pace
and then i guess on the other hand this
thing could destroy her
wrong no no it's too bad
[Music]
you